let's talk about why so many Afghans are
being deported from Pakistan take a look
at
this tens of thousands of people are on
the
move some have lived in Pakistan their
whole
lives 1.7 million Afghans were ordered
to leave by the Pakistani government and
more than 370,000 have now crossed into
aan fistan a country already in crisis
where Winter is setting in this is not
the right time for hundreds of thousands
of afans the most vulnerable to be
heading back to nothing so what's behind
this Mass deportation and what does the
Taliban government in Afghanistan have
to do with
[Music]
it Afghanistan and Pakistan are
neighbors and over the decades there
have been several waves of Afghan
refugees who've crossed that border to
escape instability or War like in 1979
when the Soviets invaded Afghanistan
when the Taliban took over the first
time in '96 after the US invaded in 2001
and again when the Taliban returned to
power in 2021 so over the years Pakistan
has become home to millions of Afghans
3.7 million before this recent
deportation drive that number includes
people with legal permission to live in
Pakistan the so-called documented
refugees as well as others who are
considered to be there illegally those
who are undocumented they're the people
being targeted by the government in
early October Pakistan's interior
Minister announced that all undocumented
immigrants had to leave the country by
November 1st or be deported by force
this pronouncement didn't call out
Afghan refugees in particular it said
all undocumented refugees but of course
the vast majority of refugees in
Pakistan are Afghan um so so it's it's
you know really thought to be uh
obviously about them so why is the
government doing this well they're
really giving a mix of reasons they say
Afghanistan is now a safe country for
Afghans to return to because the war
there is over they've also been saying
that the refugees are a burden on
Pakistan's economy but whether there's
actual evidence for that is Up For
Debate the government of Pakistan is not
providing handouts to them not providing
sanctuaries or houses for them they are
earning whatever they can and and paying
their rents paying their food everything
is is by themselves so they're not as
such a burden on the government of
Pakistan Pakistani officials are also
linking Afghan refugees to the security
threat that Pakistan is facing they say
that Afghans have been responsible for
several attacks in the country this year
interim interior Minister seaj bti
quoted without presenting any evidence
that out of the 24 suicide attacks that
he we have had in the country 14 have
been conducted by aan national but there
are are other layers to the security
issue and how the government is linking
it to refugees and those have to do with
the group known as the Pakistani Taliban
or tarika Taliban Pakistan TTP for short
they want for themselves what the aan
Taliban have achieved in in Afghanistan
essentially they want to take over
Pakistan that is not a realistic or
achievable goal in in Pakistan right so
they have an Insurgency against the
Pakistani State they certainly pose a
major security threat to
Pakistan the TTP have been behind some
of the country's worst attacks the death
toll from the taliban's horrifying
attack topping 140 almost all of them
young
students and over the last year there's
been an increase in violence in Pakistan
hundreds of attacks and more than 700
civilians and security forces killed
many of the attacks have been claimed by
or blamed on the TTP now the TTP that
Pakistani Taliban does have a
relationship with the Afghan Taliban
they're ideologically aligned and the
Afghan Taliban are accused of providing
a safe haven for the TTP to operate from
Pakistan is grappling with increased
terrorism and that terrorism does have a
link with Afghanistan but the link is
that it is the TTP that is engaging in
these attacks and it's engaging in them
because it has a sanctuary on The Afghan
uh side of the border and so uh that is
why Pakistan is facing increased
terrorism but it is um you know
disingenuously linking this increased
terrorism to Afghan refugees within
Pakistan's own territory the TTP issue
has also been straining the relationship
between Pakistan's government and the
Taliban government next door because
Pakistan wants the Afghan Taliban to do
more to help it tackle the threat from
the TTP Pakistan's State thought that
the Afghan Taliban could Prevail upon
the
TTP uh and I think the sense is that it
can Prevail upon the TTV to stop it
attacks in Pakistan but it chooses not
to so it appears that government wants
to put a clamp down and is now saying
that enough is enough we have tried to
talk to you aan Taliban a lot of times
we have given you a lot of chances we
have sent you a delegations this cannot
go on anymore in response to all this a
Taliban spokesman said it does not allow
anyone to use the territory of
Afghanistan against Pakistan and
Pakistan should solve their internal
problems by themselves and not blame
Afghanistan for their failures and a lot
of people think this dispute over the
TTP is actually one of the main reasons
that Pakistan is deporting so many
Afghan refugees there an expulsion Drive
is being used as a you know tit for D
when you send back thousands of aan
Nationals um the government over there
has to take care of them so for them it
is a headache so let's look more closely
at exactly who is being forced out of
Pakistan we mentioned that the
government is basically targeting
Afghans who were undocumented and that
includes a whole range of people it's
refugees who fled to Pakistan and were
never registered or they were registered
at some point but their documents
expired it also includes many Afghans
who were born and raised in Pakistan but
don't qualify for citizenship you you
will actually see people you know Afghan
refugees who are for all intents and
purposes Pakistani right born and raised
in Pakistan attended School in Pakistan
work in Pakistan they have absolutely no
ties at this point to Afghanistan and
they have never been there plus there's
another group among the undocumented
refugees and these are Afghans who fled
after the Taliban Takeover in 2021
because they feared for their lives many
are eligible for asylum in Western
countries like the US and UK but are
still waiting for their claims to be
processed for example there are 25,000
Afghan refugees in Pakistan who are
waiting to be resettled in the US I
think that one reason Pakistan um has uh
engaged in this policy is also to try to
put pressure on Western governments to
speed up those pending Asylum
applications after Pakistan's
announcement on deportations the UK
government sent a plane to bring around
130 refugees to the UK and Pakistani
officials say they're expecting 12 more
flights by the end of December now
remember all of these undocumented
Afghans add up to about 1.7 million
people and right after Pakistan made its
deportation announcement in early
October hundreds of thousands of Afghans
rushed to the Border leaving their whole
lives
[Music]
behind it just sent a layer of shock and
panic among all afans in the country
many afans were leaving in panic um uh
majority were telling us that they were
just fearing arrest and detention once
the November 1st deadline passed for
people to leave voluntarily Pakistani
authorities started a Crackdown to find
and Deport undocumented Afghans still in
the country this Afghan neighborhood in
Islam Abad for example was completely
bulldozed law enforcement has engaged in
uh in threats uh in in very heavy-handed
behavior and raids it is quite evident
that the drive is being used to harass
to push people away to coers them into
paying money or just get rid of them and
even though Pakistan deportation Drive
is only supposed to apply to
undocumented people there have also been
lots of reports that Afghans with the
right papers are getting caught up in it
too there are many registered refugees
or others with documents who are
approaching UNR
centers and uh saying uh that they also
are feeling the push that they needed to
leave Pakistan nearly 400,000 Afghans
have crossed the border already and
every day thousands more are coming many
have ended up in camps on The Afghan
side they're relying on Aid and figuring
out where to go next it's also getting
really really cold
and remember Afghanistan is a country
that's already dealing with a profound
humanitarian crisis more than 29 million
people in D need of humanitarian
assistant which actually about two3 of
the country population and more than 50
million people in Afghanistan do not
have access to foods and they don't know
that where their their second meals come
from so this Mass return of Afghans back
to Afghanistan is going to put an
additional layer on the top of the
already ongoing
[Music]
crisis if you want to know more about
the crisis in Afghanistan check out this
[Music]
episode